so we're about to run the new saga
function for a second time and the
important issue here is that we will
create a brand new read context which
will be the home for a new foil variable
and two new blue contexts the other
interesting thing here is that this
sagas array is going to now have two
different function objects in it as a
result of the second call to dot push
let's examine this situation further by
imagining that there were even more
calls to the two different saga
functions here before the end of the
program running the first saga function
again should work just like it did the
other times we ran it even though we've
created a second new saga context and as
we can see as we run the code running
that inner sagas function creates a new
blue sagas context inside the first red
new saga context that's because we're
running the first of those saga
functions the first of the saga
functions was created in the first of
the new saga contexts what do you expect
the output to be this time